bonjour qui sur jacob nous a déclassé en
tout cas merci d'être avec nous ce matin
en direct une question un peu personnel
pour commencer on sort aujourd'hui de
deux mois totalement inédit où on a été
confiné chez nous vous avez été
christian jacob l'un des premiers hommes
politiques à avoir été contaminés par le
virus vous avez guéri mais qu'avez vous
appris de ces deux mois inédit avez vous
changé évolué dans votre rapport à la
politique aux autres et même à la vie
d'abord fonctionnement au quotidien à
serques au quotidien on a pu au siège du
parti on a travaillé énormément en
visioconférence là je faisais le compte
en deux mois c'est plus de 50
visioconférence que j'ai j'ai suivi donc
c'est vrai que ça n'est pas l'idéal ceci
étant ça a permis de travailler pendant
ce temps là ça a permis de maintenir des
contacts
bon on est pressé d'avoir à nouveau de
vraies réunions mais mais je pense que
bon malgré tout on a découvert aussi
qu'on pouvait travailler différemment
mais vous personnellement intimement
est-ce quelque chose qui a changé chez
vous entendrez politique pas écouté j'ai
passé deux mois sept jours sur sept avec
mon épouse il ya longtemps que ça ne
nous était pas arrivé
et alors et tout s'est bien passé
très bien allez on y va le gouvernement
a jugé que la france était prête à lever
progressivement le confinement le
gouvernement va mettre 10 millions de
masques à disposition des français
notamment dans les transports les tests
sont prêts dit le ministre de la santé
vous vous êtes abstenu lors du vote du
plan de déconfinement à l'assemblée
nationale dit vous ce matin que la
france est prête au déconfinement
écoutez je pense que oui oro s'est
abstenu parce que il ya un climat de
défiance on a reproché au gouvernement
d'avoir disons pour être prudents les
des contre vérités sur les masques sur
les tests d'avoir pris
beaucoup de retard ceci étant il était
important de sortir du confinement et
que l'économie puisse puisse redémarrer
donc on voit bien les difficultés que ça
peut présenter dans les écoles dans les
transports mais ceci étant il fallait
sortir du confinement à partir du moment
où les conditions sanitaires le
permettait le conseil constitutionnel
statue aura finalement ce soir sur la
loi d'état d'urgence puisqu'il ya eu un
petit retard dans la promulgation de la
loi
l'état d'urgence sanitaire doit être
donc est prolongée jusqu'au 10 juillet
cet état d'urgence sanitaire est il
légitime à vos yeux s'il devait être à
nouveau allongé est ce que vous le
voteriez clairement non je pense que il
faut en sortir alors sauf bien entendu
si les conditions sanitaires nous
l'imposent ce serait autre chose mais on
voit bien que la démocratie est sous
cloche
c'est ce mode de fonctionnement de de
l'assemblée nationale n'est pas n'est
pas idéal avec un système de vote bloqué
avec très peu de avec très peu de débat
sur des enjeux qui sont énormes
il faut il faut encore une fois que la
démocratie puisse reprendre ses droits
et puis les pouvoirs exorbitants du
droit commun mais nous les avons voté
med de donner au gouvernement cette
possibilité de fonctionner par
ordonnance il faut il faut en sortir et
pour ma part comme pour beaucoup de nos
collègues le 10 juillet était une
position de compromis mon était beaucoup
plus favorable à le limiter jusqu'au 24
juin c'est à dire un mois de
prolongement mais de prolongation n'est
pas davantage un enfant sur six se
retourne à l'école cette semaine l'école
ne sera pas une garderie dit jean michel
blanquer air qui souhaite que chaque
enfant soit retournée à l'école au moins
une fois d'ici fin mai au moins pour
prendre de ses nouvelles psychologique
lui demander comment y va et aussi pour
retrouver même brièvement la
collectivité une fois à chaque enfant
qui retourne au moins une fois d'ici fin
mai vous trouvez que c'est faisable vous
pensez que c'est faisable
écoutez on va voir moi je pense que là
aussi il ya eu beaucoup de tâtonnements
et puis 2 2
positionnement différent d'entre eux le
miz d'éducation nationale le président
de la république le premier ministre
ceci étant il est important que les
enfants puissent puisse retourner à
l'école pour que les choses auraient pu
se faire différemment mais mais ceci
étant oui je pense que c'est essentiel
fin avril vous souhaitiez la réouverture
des cas ces restaurants dès aujourd'hui
dès le 11 mai dans les départements les
moins touchés vous le pensez encore ce
matin au vu des inquiétudes des français
sur le déconfinement oui je pense qu'à
partir du moment où on est ou ce qu'on
avait dit c'est qu'il fallait tenir
compte de la réalité du terrain
lorsqu'on est dans des départements où
il n'y a pas de cas où très peu il en
existe un certain nombre ou les
conditions de distanciation sont mises
en place
écoutez moi je pense qu'on peut plus
vite on redémarre l'économie encore une
fois il s'agit pas de faire n'importe
quoi il s'agit de cibler sur des
départements où il ya eu peu de cas
référence et j'ai pris l'exemple à
l'époque du du cantal où il y avait eu
aucun cas où un seul je crois mais il ya
d'autres départements dans cette
situation il faut que l'économie
redémarre donc vous auriez par exemple
dans le cantal vous auriez souhaité par
exemple dans le cantal que les cafés les
restaurants les hôtels soit rouvert
aujourd'hui à partir du moment où on met
bien entendu des règles de distanciation
vous savez on l'a fait dans nous sur nos
marchés avec les autorisations des
préfets le marché de provins a continué
à fonctionner à ça
à être couvert toutes les toutes les
semaines et je pense pas que c'est
présenté de difficultés particulières
alors c'est sûr que pour les commerçants
c'est compliqué pour les gens qui comme
moi font leur marché aussi mais plus
vite l'économie redémarre mieux c'est
pour soutenir l'économie le gouvernement
n'a pas lésiné sur les mesures chômage
partiel fonds de soutien pour les
commerçants et les indépendants toutes
ces mesures coûtent cher très cher le
déficit la dette explose dites vous ce
matin que c'était ce qu'il fallait faire
que le gouvernement a eu raison quoi
qu'il en compte
quoi qu'il en coûte à nos comptes
publics a de toute façon il fallait
faire fonctionner les amortisseurs
sociaux et notamment le chômage partiel
en revanche je pense qu'il faut aussi en
sortir rapidement par exemple est ce
qu'on ne pourrait pas dès que l'économie
redémarre que l'argent public est mis
sur le chômage partiel servent à faire
de la baisse de charges de façon à
pouvoir encore une fois relancé la
relancer la machine mais il fallait
d'abord apporter une réponse à la crise
sanitaire
ensuite faire en sorte que la crise
économique soit la moins profonde est la
moins durable possible pour éviter le
choc social qui va s'ensuivre
faut-il que les français travaillent
plus grande des jours fériés ou des rtt
comme le suggère le medef pour aider
l'économie à se relever
moi je pense que healy a effectivement
il faut se sortir du carcan des des 35
heures
la proposition que nous avions fait aux
républicains il ya déjà quelques temps
c'est de dire qu'on peut très bien le
faire dans le cas de l'annualisation du
temps de travail et de le faire par
entreprise aux plus proches aidants de
deuil de la réalité est dans une
négociation sociale entre les les
salariés d'une entreprise
le chef d'entreprise et voir
effectivement si on peut pas déclencher
les heures supplémentaires à la 37e à la
38e à la 39e heures ou à la 40e heures
ce qui permettrait aux salariés d'avoir
une augmentation de salaire et donc de
pouvoir d'achat et de redonner de la
compétitivité aux entreprises
la question du temps de travail devra se
poser mais dans un cadre de dialogue
social et dans l'entreprise ou dans les
branches lorsqu'on a on est sur de
petites entreprises ça ne peut pas être
décidé par l'état il faut laisser cette
liberté ou salariés qui travaillent dans
une entreprise à devoir effectivement
comment on peut améliorer leur pouvoir
d'achat
et comment on peut baisser le coût du
travail est plus complète et d'aucune
chine une semaine de travail de 40
heures vous dit pourquoi pas à partir du
moment où c'est un accord social qui est
passé au sein de l'entreprise moi ça non
seulement ça ne me choque pas mais je
pense que c'est une réponse qui peut
être apportée on gagnerait sur le peu
sur tous les fronts c'est à dire haut de
la fiche de paye s'en trouveraient
améliorées et la compétitivité de
l'entreprise aussi les municipales
christian jacob on ne sait toujours pas
quand elles auront lieu le second tour
si ce sera en juin ou à l'automne que
souhaite le patron de la droite que vous
êtes quel est votre préconisations
christian jacob
tout d'abord installer très rapidement
les maires élus au premier tour je
rappelle que 30000 mer sur 35 mille ont
été élus le gouvernement se moque du
monde et nous emmène en bateau sur le
sujet jeudi rien n'empêche aujourd'hui
d'installer ces maires élus au premier
tour
les conseils municipaux en moyenne
notamment sur ceux qui ont été élus au
premier tour c'est une quinzaine de
personnes non comme nous raconte pas
qu'on ne peut pas le faire et que le
premier ministre vous explique pas qu'il
a besoin de consulter le comité
scientifique
on peut installer les maires aujourd'hui
ne pas les installer
c'est créer des chômeurs de plus on ne
redémarre pas dominique seux le disais
tout à l'heure un secteur comme les
travaux publics sont très dépendants de
la commande publique et donc ce secteur
qui va avoir une baisse de production
importantes il faut qu'il redémarre et
pour ça il faut que les conseils sur le
second tour sur les second tour on joue
sur le long terme d'écouter dès que les
conditions sanitaires le permettent ça
veut dire concrètement si on est capable
d'ouvrir les écoles les collèges les
lycées les commerces je ne vois pas au
nom de quoi le deuxième tour ne
pourraient pas se tenir en juin
maintenant si les conditions sanitaires
ne permettent pas la mf l'association
des maires de france a fait une
proposition
tout à fait raisonnable qui est celle de
septembre christian jacob était notre
invité belle journée à vous